something really interesting going on in the
youtube space over the last week or so.
You might know that for the last couple of
of years
there have been struggles on youtube that
the David Pakman show channel has experienced.
The first one was back in April of 2017.
Back then we were sort of a middle of the
road size channel and uh, we've also struggled
more recently in some other areas.
Now we are sort of in the top one or 2% of
Youtube and the struggles that we're having
now are pretty different from the ones that
we were having a couple of years ago.
As a result of different algorithm, algorithmic
and advertising related changes to the platform.
And very often whenever I talk about youtube
woes, people will write to me and they'll
say, Hey David, you should unionize on youtube
so that all of you channels could bargain
together with youtube for monetization and
status.
And I've actually spoken to entertainment
lawyers about this casually.
And typically what they say is that youtube
is set up legally in the United States.
Uh, in a way that current law would not easily
allow a unionization of Youtube burrs without
wholesale changes to the law regarding independent
contractors and employees and a whole bunch
of other things.
However, European law is different and there
is a huge movement in Europe for a whole bunch
of youtubers to unionize and to bargain collectively
for light rights with Youtube.
So this is potentially huge and I'm going
to talk about it in detail, but before we
even get into that, I also need to be very
honest with you.
I don't think I'd be interested in being a
part of this youtube or as union at this point
in time based on our challenge size.
On our channel size, and I'll explain to you
why I support unions.
I think collective bargaining is a great way
for individual players to get more clout and
have more control over their circumstances.
I support teachers' unions.
I support factory workers, unions and transportation
workers, unionizing and pilots, sports league
players, the whole thing.
But that being said right now, given that
my channel is one of the, you know, in the
top one or 2% of Youtube, I don't believe
it would be to my advantage to get into a
union unless it's a union of news and politics,
Youtube burrs that are my size or larger,
which are relatively few.
And what I mean by that is now that my channel
is run as a part of a broader business that
is very different than what it was even two
years ago when we had a couple hundred thousand
subscribers, there is no way that a consortium
or a union of channels that are not just using
politics that are everything from makeup and
gaming and sports and whatever else, uh, and
drastically different sizes.
There's no way that it would be to my advantage
to be in that union because our needs and
our circumstances are now so different than
those of the majority of youtube channels.
Now you might hear me say this and react by
saying, oh, David, that's because your channel
is successful.
That's, that's why I mean I'm recognizing
that I'm not denying it.
I want the full freedom to do or not do anything
I want on Youtube.
I want the freedom to put my content or not
on any other platforms that I want.
I am actually at the point where only a union
of the top news and politics channels would
actually be useful and that would arguably
defeat the kind of egalitarian nature of the
union to begin with because the truth is that
at this point, even if youtube screws me,
I don't know that being part of a union like
the one in Europe would benefit me.
This is why I left TYT network years ago.
It had nothing to do with conflict with TYT
of any kind.
It was just that I'm the most nimble and free
to do what's right for my channel.
If I'm not affiliated with anything else at
a smaller size, I might trade that.
A advantage for being part of the union right
now, it's simply wouldn't make, but let's
explore what they're doing because this is
serious.
This could actually have a really major impact
on youtube.
The Youtube has union Europe has joined with
Igg metal, which is Germany's largest union
and Europe's largest trade union to launch
fair tube.
This is the most significant Youtube Related
Organization of Labor that we have ever seen.
Here are their demands monetize.
Everyone bring back monetization for smaller
channels which was taken away disabled.
The bots at least verified partners have the
right to speak to a real person if you plan
to remove their channel.
Transparent content decisions, open up direct
communication between the sensors and the
creators.
Pay for the views.
Stop using demonetized channels as bait to
advertise, monetized channels.
Stop the monetization as a whole.
If a video is in line with your rules, allow
ads on an even scale equal treatment for all
partners.
Stop preferring some content creators over
others.
Pay according to delivered values, spread
out the ad money over all youtubers based
on audience retention, not on ads.
Next to the content and clarify the rules
block.
Bring out clear rules with clear examples
about what's okay and what isn't.
The deadline for Youtube to respond is August
23 so far, no comment from youtube so this
is really great, but if you look at the list
of demands, you will see that it is all based
on the connection between ad dollars and content
in the same way that Obamacare did good things,
but it also further ingrained the for profit
healthcare system that we have by giving tens
of millions of new customers to for-profit
insurers.
The demands that are being made here are excellent,
obviously well calibrated demands that reinforce
the status quo in which content creators are
given dollars via people watching advertising
funded by advertisers buying an ad contract
with youtube.
This is only a bandaid.
This is not a cure for the disease.
Half of these demands would go away if we
completely reprogrammed how content works,
if instead of having to make money by having
a video that advertisers say meets their standards
of what's okay, so that they will run an ad
and give a dollar to youtube from which the
content creator gets 40 cents or 50 cents
or however much it is, this goes away, which
is why I've been pushing for us to fund shows
we like directly, period.
I am supportive of this movement.
This particular union is not the right thing
for the David Pakman show at this point in
time, but I want it to succeed.
But the real way to solve this is separate.
The ad dollars from the content by funding
shows directly.
Hundreds and hundreds of you in the last couple
of months have said, I understand the importance
of that, and you've signed up for memberships,
for example, on our website, www.joinpackman.com
that severs the tie between advertisers and
our content.
That is a very good thing.
Hundreds of you have become patrons donating
as little as a dollar a month to our show
at patrion.com/david Pakman show.
I support the union and I wish it wasn't necessary
by changing the system to one where we fund
directly the programs that we want.
I hope you'll consider doing that.